coming off the loss to atlanta the
raiders now prepare for the winless jets
sports director chris matthew fresh off
the links joining us now in studio
with more in a game the raiders can't
take for granted chris
well not this one this is one of those
scary games brian because the jets are
owed 11 on the season
and the raiders are coming off their
worst performance of the year you know
the jets will be hungry and motivated
to get their first win of the season and
they've got to be feeling pretty good
about the raiders remember last year
when the
vegas raiders met and met life with a
bunch of confidence
and got rocked by new york 34-3 so if
anybody knows the kind of motivation the
jets will use to beat the raiders again
it's john gruden he's preparing his team
the best he can he certainly understands
that new york will be extra motivated to
beat the raiders this
team here las vegas will be extra
motivated because they don't want to be
the team giving the jets their first win
of the season
the raiders are starving for wins we
haven't been in the postseason
i don't know when in a long time i don't
really worry about anybody else's
mindset i worry about our mindset we
have to have a starving to death
mentality
to get back into postseason and the jets
are going to play hard you watch that
game last week against miami
you watch them play uh close against the
chargers every week
they're they're a handful but we got to
worry about ourselves
we have to have a collective urgency to
to play our best football this week no
matter who we play
all right now on paper sunday's game
looks like a dud the writer scoring just
six points against atlanta while the
jets manage just
three against uh miami we should say
atlanta then the jets is three against
miami now the raiders
have won two of the last three against
the jets however